aux produits du coteaux d'aix et là vous
allez ça nos rosés
des bleus
un peu partout
[Musique]
e
non mais de patienter jusque leur
secours autour d'eux
j'vous retrouvailles même cheville et
les rosés en provence est vrai qu'on est
assez au point sur les techniques
c'est par cours d'oenologie c'est
vraiment un partage entre eux et moi
vigneronne donc je leur donne quelques
conseils de dégustation et surtout
quelques anecdotes sur la manière de
produire le vin oui les produits notre
notre philosophie
voilà donc ils ont l'impression d'en
apprendre un peu plus à la fin de la
dégustation ils ont passé un moment
convivial et
[Musique]
brad est aujourd'hui fait interpellé
solitaire les hommes les uns les autres
[Musique]
on sait d'ores et déjà qu'on aura peu ou
pas de touristes étrangers alors on a
une
grosse clientèle habituellement de
touristes venus d'europe du nord
[Musique]
on espère que les touristes françaises
au rendez-vous et que peut-être que
certains de ceux qui avaient prévu de
partir à l'étranger
privilégions des vacances en france et
pourquoi pas en provence
et par chaîne ce serait sympa
on
nous on
[Musique]